[Music]
now full of orion johnston video yeah
this is the best part is that stromedy
alex wasabi
and that ryan johnson guy i pretty sure
i recognize ryan johnson because i think
i've watched one of his videos before
when i was doing my like family vlog
video maybe sure
right yeah i think he does like family
vlogs i have no clue i just went to his
page and i saw him like a bunch of
pictures with his kid
and they were colored like a six nine
video and i was like yes
yes is this it is this ryan johnson
video i think so
okay so yeah but they all make videos
for kids
oh do they yeah that's the things
dramadee's videos are like
targeted at children like they all do
like the you know crazy over exaggerated
stronghold he does videos the his videos
are like the um
you know walking into a haunted forest
at 3am with a drone
why is bryce and they like watch a drone
screen and they fly their drone like and
then they have someone in a clown suit
like run out of the forest and they're
like oh my [ __ ] god did you see that
dog
and they do like two videos like this
every single week and then
yeah through our eyes that's what it's
called all these videos are targeted for
children
so so they make videos for kids and then
they're and they're in the boxing it's
just weird
i just don't get how bryce could care
that someone like that was talking [ __ ]
about him
it's like bryce and taylor train you
know a couple days a week
like who gives a [ __ ] a kid's creator is
like oh [ __ ] you up
who cares i don't i don't really get it
i don't know
i don't know man the the footage in that
so fussy did another video where they
fought and they took the footage out of
the fight
just play this no volume while we're
talking luke yeah we don't need to hear
it
that's for sure yeah sorry keep going no
it's i'm kind of curious to see what
this is
yeah all right we got a pug in the first
five i mean that's a great way to start
i love puzzles
but i'm a big we already know what this
is
you know after doug it's just everybody
trying to hire a third actor in their
home
yeah sorry what were you saying though
um
i'm sorry yeah you know no disrespect to
the dude but i know he's nuts
it just like this style of vlogging
at this deep in youtube you
really don't give a [ __ ] what do you
mean
like to just be in 2021
like this like just [ __ ] like
what is up guys today we're going to the
forest my dog is here like
like it's just it's nuts filming people
straight out the shower
like i think audiences and stuff are
hypersensitive to what you do now
so i think there's this element of
people where they think about these
things and this dude's like nah it's all
on camera
everything yeah but this isn't even this
isn't even like a normal vlog like
i'm not talking like i feel like roman
atwood you ever watched one of his vlogs
yeah yeah yeah he's genuinely like
it kind of seems like those are just
vlogging our life you know like here's
our life
and it's a lot of older family people
that watch those because they're like i
want to see another family
that's true but these types where it's
like all like go to his thumbnails
for a second and i don't know maybe i'm
passing judgment too early maybe i'm not
like remembering this guy's channel
correctly but i'm pretty sure
it's one of these where scroll down
like what do these thumbnails say
like all caps lock like they're all like
half of them are kind of fake
like they do like fake sketches sort of
where they're pretending that someone's
cheating on someone yeah
like catching my girl pranking mike oh
yeah maybe he was the one that
they did like a baby dropping prank
that's where i say
i think that's what i'm getting at when
i say he's nuts is in his eyeballs
and his content seems like he has that
level of commitment where
it does not matter to him what anybody
says about his videos
yeah yeah he just knows what he's gonna
do to put on for his kid
and like his family yeah that's fair and
glory to god
search nick austin baby drop prank real
quick i just want to see if i'm thinking
about the right video
let's just get that information right
austin no oh no it wasn't nick austin
sorry what was his name
i have no clue nick what was the [ __ ] is
what
are you talking about this guy we were
just watching stromedy
no thank you ryan johnson's ryan johnson
you're just making up names
austin rhymes we get
i think i got the like smooshy space
brain right now yeah
yeah here we go i dropped the baby yes
so i am thinking about the right video
so this
pause it for a sec maybe and maybe try
and like find the place where
they drop it but this is the prank okay
they get a fake baby they have a baby
right him and his wife yeah
and then he goes up to like the second
floor looking over the
like the railing while his wife is in
the living room and he drops the fake
baby off the thing
to get his wife's reaction is that not
the most [ __ ] up prank you've ever
heard in your entire life
yeah it is i want to see it
now granted i think that this is staged
honestly because there's no way you'd
actually do this to your
real-life wife no i mean it's seductive
i mean
uh did you see that tick tock where the
wife trips into the kitchen and throws a
fake baby in the air and the husband
catches it it was hysterical okay
oh okay this is different though is that
that's a little bit different
maybe yeah because you're sort of this
is like drop like the baby is dead if
this is real the baby died
yeah that's true yeah i love this
insidious angle
he's carrying that thing pro
he's really milking it and oh wait you
can
do it with volume yeah we're gonna do
volume [ __ ] it
[Music]
um
oh no this is the real baby oh yeah so
now he switches it
yeah do not get in a boxing ring with
this dude
do not box this dude
he's like [ __ ] the railing too
[Music]
what what did i do wrong
that posit is he just dropped a baby
and then and then go you got pranky
prank and then did a fortnight
celebration on the rail
you got pranky prank on a pole
oh man it's so like pranked
he slid on a pole
he was ass first he doesn't respect her
at all he went ask first
you got pranky pranked stupid
you got pranky pranked
wow it's crazy right yeah so i agree
with you i think this guy is
going to be a monster in the ring yeah
he's the next he's the one to be afraid
of from
as far as earth youtube fighting
predictions go
yeah i know we're kind of up here right
now it doesn't really matter but yeah if
we were to predict
kind of the next i think ryan johnson
brian johnson maybe
yeah i think that's the fight to make
because i think ryan johnson would just
have a
peculiar like personality that maybe
jake wouldn't really know how to deal
with yeah
like imagine oh dude imagine he
this is beating up jake paul in the ring
and he's like you getting pranky pranked
right now bro
i'm getting cranky pranked wow wow how
does it feel to get a little pranky
prank
pop pop i'm not getting pranky pranks
pop pop t-pose yeah
yes you are yes you are yeah dude
um that would be the ultimate [ __ ] you
knock someone out and then just t pose
you